and the bite administration has made a
big show of going after those domestic
extremists that molly was talking about
they're lurking in the shadows so
imagine our surprise when
he seeks to elevate one into his own
administration
fox's own trace gallagher has the story
from our west coast newsroom trace what
is this about
well laura tracy stone manning is
president biden's pick to head the
bureau of land management when she was a
graduate student back in 1989 stone
manning was a member of the
environmental group
earth first and was linked to an
eco-terrorism case of tree spiking
in idaho's clearwater forest now tree
spiking is where you hammer a metal rod
into a tree to protect it from being cut
down tree spikes can also break or
shatter saw blades
putting in grave danger stone manning
was investigated in the case but struck
an immunity deal with the government
and testified against two men who were
later convicted
stone manning now tells the senate
energy committee that she had no prior
knowledge
of the tree spiking plot and several
media outlets bought it in fact because
so many stories
represented stone manning as a bystander
or a victim
retired forest service investigator
michael merkley who led the case
wrote a letter to the senate committee
calling stone manning the quote
nastiest of suspects saying she wasn't
just a member of earth first she was
part of the hierarchy adding quoting
here
she was vulgar antagonistic and
extremely anti-government
she was very uncooperative and refused
to provide the hair
handwriting exemplars and fingerprints
as
ordered by the federal grand jury former
investigator merkley ended by saying
he eventually learned that stone manning
knew all along
who committed the tree spiking crime now
gop senator john barrasso the ranking
member on the energy committee says
he believes stone manning lied to the
committee and that president biden
should withdraw her nomination
which apparently is not going to happen
because despite the former
investigator's letter
the white house is sticking by stone
manning saying she is quote
exceptionally qualified we should note
that democratic senator joe manchin who
could be the deciding vote has not yet
revealed
which way he's leaning but he calls
stone manning
a good person laura the ultimate
washington power broker trace thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else